so you want to build a commander deck
building a commander can be quite a
daunting task pulling together 99 cards
that work well together under your
chosen Commander is no small feat and
after 15 years of playing the game I'd
like to think I'd learn a little bit
about building decks so here are seven
mistakes you should avoid when building
your first commander deck
if you only take away one thing from
this video it should be this tip here
make sure you're playing enough lands in
your commander deck there's nothing
worse than not drawing your third land
and watching your opponents play
Commander while you slowly die inside
the general rule of thumb is to aim for
about 37 lands if we crunch the numbers
with 37 lands in your deck you have a
91.6 chance to draw two lands in your
first nine cards you see your opening
seven plus your first and second turn
draw for the turn
you'll also have an 80 chance to see
three lands by your third turn
in which case you should have enough
Mana to cast a spell or one of these
important cards we're going to talk
about next
now hopefully you've already actioned my
last Point as looking after your Mana
doesn't stop there the next thing
players often forget about is not having
enough Mana rocks
minor rocks is the nickname given to
artifacts that generate Mana the most
common ones being soul ring and Arcane
Signet
to put it simply Mana rocks are just
extra lands you can play during your
turn for a small cost being able to play
your commander or key spells a turn
earlier is always important
so to summarize these two tips about
Mana you generally want to aim for about
45 total minor sources about 37 lands
give or take and about 5 to 10 Mana
rocks or other minor sources
if you're new to Magic you might not
have heard this term before
what do I mean by having interaction
to put it simply to have interaction in
your commander deck simply means to have
cards that interact with your opponent's
cards
the most common form of interaction is
removal and counter spells having
interaction with your deck allows you to
take out opposing key permanence and
protect your own things
in most of my decks I aim for about five
to eight removal spells that can Target
a mix of Planeswalkers artifacts
enchantments and of course creatures
there are plenty of budget-friendly
spells that can Target multiple things
so look to include those two I would
also highly recommend running at least
two board wipes spells that destroy
everything of a certain type
Blasphemous act wrath of God and
Damnation are the most commonly played
options but there are plenty out there
and our next tip will make sure you have
all of these key cards exactly when you
need them
games of Commander are generally won by
the person who has the most card
advantage or has drawn more cards from
their deck
being able to dig deeper into your deck
means you're more likely to find your
key cards minor ramp and other answers
you may need
every color has some access to card draw
and I always like to have about 10 cards
that draw me cards these can be split
across your instance sorceries creatures
and other permanence
if you're able to have cards that offer
repeatable card draw effects like the
great henge NIV Miser Draco genius or
mine's eye well that's even better
Okay so we've got our Mana sorted
interaction locked and loaded and plenty
of card draw so we're not just sitting
dead in the water after a few unlucky
draws
it seems obvious but we need to make
sure we've got a couple of ways to
actually win the game
this could involve running a combo that
wins you the game on the spot or it
could just be a devastating spell or
creature that wins you the game if
you're betting on your commander to win
you the game just make sure you have
enough support pieces and protection
spells to keep them around to do so
picking your commander is one of the
hardest decisions you can make in Magic
it's just like picking your first
starter Pokemon and thankfully it's a
decision that gets easier over time the
more you play
however thanks to the internet it is
very easy just to go to EDH Rec look at
the top 10 Commander list and pick one
of those and Away you go but you might
not have any fun just doing that
I would highly recommend having a look
through your collection and ask yourself
what sort of cards do I enjoy playing is
there a legendary creature that fits
that kind of theme
Commander is a brilliant format where
there is no right answer anyone can tell
you
at the end of the day you shouldn't
listen to what others are saying and
just pick what you enjoy playing
and if you need some suggestions well
feel free to ask in the comments down
below and we'll do our best to help you
out
focusing on perfection
I've been playing Magic for over 15
years and this still trips me up I have
a silly amount of Unfinished Commander
Decks that I could probably finish up
and have ready to go but the voice
inside me tells me it's not ready yet
if you're still working on your first
commander deck just slap some cards in
there and get it finished the best way
to learn if you enjoy your commander
deck or not is to just get out there and
play with the deck with some real people
you've just got a punch perfection in
the face whip out your deck and just
start playing
that's about all the tips I've got for
you aspiring Commander players is there
any other advice I've missed let us know
in the comments down below
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you in the next one